m
marie grondin 87 ans à son âge il est
difficile pour elle d' entretenir sa
cour tous les trois mois les agents du
glaive se rendent chez elle gratuitement
pour tondre élaguer et nettoyer son
jardin ah bah moi je crois pour faire
rapporter au moins on est satisfait
parce que ces personnes âgées sa maman
ne m'a pas trop on n'a pas trop les
moyens et mâcha de faire ça donc on a vu
lev et puis ben voilà il faut un travail
extraordinaire on est content et ça nous
apporte plein chose à la le glaive
dispense gratuitement ses services
auprès des personnes en difficulté ce
sol ces actions sont financées par le
département elles permettent aux
personnes âgées handicapées et aux
bénéficiaires de minima sociaux
d'améliorer leur cadre de vie grâce au
nettoyage de leurs cours et à l'
enlèvement des encombrants
le glaive est une association de loi
1901 qui a été créée en 2006 à l'origine
le glaive a été créé pour ce en pleine
crise du chikungunya pour s'occuper de
la démoustication et de leur enlever les
larves qui traînait dans les parages
ensuite le show culinaire est invité a
été maîtrisé le glaive un peu évolué et
maintenant le glaive rend service aux
particuliers en nettoyant leurs cours en
est là dans les arbres qui pose problème
est également en aidant les personnes
âgées donc neuf à ce titre un rôle
éminemment social il a un rôle également
économique et surtout un rôle d'aider la
population à la mesure où le glaive
intervient essentiellement chez des
personnes âgées et qui ne sont pas
imposables
les agents affectés à l'ensemble de ses
prestations sont employés en contrat
aidé il s'agit en particulier de publics
en difficulté
l'objectif est de les inscrire dans une
démarche d'insertion et de
professionnalisation
ils sont contre à ces huiles ont pas eu
d une idée assez et
ces personnes là sont des personnes qui
ce mal et c'était des jeunes qui n'ont
jamais travaillé
ben
l'association les pm et de pouvoir
verser l'eau
on va il
ça le rend si six points qui motivent et
pour l'avenir avoir de l'ambition
même s'ils ont un parcours de deux ans
mais ça les aide à reprendre confiance
en eux et
et passons
on a pris pas de l'été samedi au glaive
suivent toujours une formation et sort
toujours avec un petit bagage si le
glaive
ouais merci passée baisse il fallait que
nous on faisait tous ça
fermez là on aurait déposé depuis sa
création en 2006 le glaive à réaliser
1890 dossier évacuer 4110 tonnes de
déchets et a délivré deux cent quinze
contrats aidés